all this kumbaya crap about just do it
for love is [ __ ] end of the day if
you got to keep the lights on writer you
think somebody in the world of
government uh something uh that's going
to save you and you're not changing at
all and you're not finding new friends
that are doing things a different way
we no longer or take control of our
lives many of us we allow the rest of
the world to take care take take our
responsibilities from us and make us
their problem need motivation watch a
top ten of belief nation what's up at
seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded onto the world so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from waiting tables at Red Lobster to
becoming a fashion entrepreneur speaker
author and investor on Shark Tank
he's Daymond John and here's my take on
his top ten rooms a success volume to
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one my personal favorite don't
chase money I had this idea that I was
going to you know buy and sell crash
cars right so I'll buy it at five
thousand put twenty five hundred into it
and then sell it at ten thousand it's
simple and if you put the math together
I was gonna do that every month and then
they would start compounding in two
three years I was gonna be a designer
yeah pretty much simple I had it all
planned out with that coke and I love I
love joking saying mike tyson's you know
theory is uh you know everybody has a
plan until i get punched in the face and
life will punch you in the face I pretty
much got punched in the face Bryce six
months into it and then I found myself
working a Red Lobster with none of that
money because I was trying to do it for
money yeah you know I hate I really hate
working on cars because I can't work on
them my hands are really buttery so my
hands feel like veal I'm not supposed to
work on a car man and I'm thinking you
know you know that about yourself though
I love that you know well I do it myself
after the first transmission you know
crush my foot and I really like you know
what I think I think hats are better you
know so but again you know a lot of
people out there chasing their dream but
their dream is to just be rich and
that's not a dream you know if you if
you if you if you try to go out and make
just make money for the purpose of
making money first of all you could end
up in the wrong place due to it you
could be miserable and then when you get
it if you don't have no goal on why you
were trying to achieve this goal you
feel unfulfilled yeah rule number two
defy the odds I'm most proud of being
able to escape the clutches of everybody
else's goals that they set for me when I
was 16 and 20 years old like most of the
people that grew up in neighborhoods
that uh that people told me are gonna be
dead or in jail or they weren't good
because of their color of their skin or
education because they didn't have any
money and I escaped those I escaped
those goals that was set for me by
society by people in the neighborhood
had the right support system around them
and I defied those those odds and I
became a person that I'm very proud of
Who I am today and people could look at
me and say if he can make it I could
make it
rule number three have a good morning
routine my morning routine five years
ago was I would get up and I would look
at my emails a couple of them I wouldn't
let them consume me because I'm Dyslexic
and I know that when you read it takes
more of the brain to utilize to read it
so I would use it to stimulate my brain
all right I'll get up I'll read my goals
like I've always done and I would try to
eat something healthy and then I would
get to the office because I was like I
can't work out too early because number
one there's a lot of fires I need to put
out and I can't do that as I started to
realize what was going on I said do
these interviews of people I started
saying all right may I need to change
this around so now it's slowly different
so I get up I'll do my goals I will
still do that small part of reading the
email but I will not look at social
media which I used to and now I'll gonna
work out because I used to work out at
night when I felt that my emails weren't
coming in that much and I wanted to kind
of get tired so I rested but I start
working out now early earlier in the day
and and I start also scheduling time
with my daughter and with my family to
make sure that that is priority over
anything else
and I also schedule any kind of health
things I need to do doctor's checkups
physicals whatever the case is what that
did was I'm more productive because the
adrenaline running and I got to work and
I'm I'm I'm more active I didn't eat the
egg and cheese sandwich was slowing me
down right and I need to chill out for a
little while I started doing my spending
more time with my family and because I
started to say I'm gonna make a major
appointment any kind of point when I can
once a month for my health I end up
finding out I had stage two cancer after
reading after son to find out all you
know all these people's techniques
because I looked further into my health
and I end up finding out I had stage 2
cancer and it didn't save my life
necessary because I had thyroid cancer
which would still be a challenge but I
had a surgery and I got the cancer wound
I'm cancer-free and and it was because
of me altering my life with these small
adjustments rule number four
ask yourself why a lot of people don't
ask themselves why yeah do I want more
cars more jets and so that no I don't I
I speaking of mr. Cuban I I go to Dallas
one day and I'm you know I'm like man
mark I never I never been to your office
man
tell me about it's the man's all kind of
thing it was huge probably right and
because and he's like alright I'll meet
you and then he comes to the hotel in
his pajamas and this is what sidekicks
without looking at his sidekick and I
said okay why am i good I mean I said I
wanna go your office he said I haven't
been in three years I said what do mean
you haven't been the office in three
years he said what am i what do I want
more money he said I want his chill home
with my son the jakester I want to
answer my things here I but I'm like but
why do you publicly give out your email
if you don't want more work he's like I
enjoy sitting at home in my pajamas
looking at this stuff and I you know and
I realize you know he's just like me why
are you doing things you have to ask
yourself right and that is your
discipline right why am I going to work
every single day and of course I
understand a lot of people here don't
have the luxury like I am afforded now
and you have to go to work you have to
you have to keep the lights on and all
this kumbaya crap about just do it for
love is [ __ ] end of the day if you
got to keep the lights on right or
there's a crack but but but uh you gotta
ask yourself why rule number five have a
good team what would you say is your
unique a superpower picking good people
yeah I am I am I am not the smartest
person in the world but I have you know
I have this knack for picking good
people I had this knack also for
allowing people to fail and seeing the
good within them and when other
everybody else goes uh you know they are
short-tempered with the people or
whatever the cases I figure I figured
that just like an entrepreneurship if
this stuff has failed between you and I
and you didn't do a good job I know one
less thing I can give you but now where
can I give you stuff that is that makes
you who you are and I think that that
that's my neck I give a lot of people a
lot of chances but they it ends up
coming back to me double and triple
their in value because they are amazing
people yeah
and what's the thing you see that you
look for when you can pick them so is it
like a feeling right away there's no I
never feel right away
there's no feel right away because they
have to unfold the the you know they're
the you know everybody's on their best
behavior when you first meet them
they'll take the onion off exactly so
it's Drive right it's that they think
outside the box they're problem solvers
they're also able to communicate
throughout a team and the system and
they have a very clear vision on the
things that they like and they know how
to communicate that to everybody else
everybody else could kind of see their
way they may not be good in one area but
it doesn't matter if I you know I you
know if I pick a person I'll put them in
any area you know I mean and they'll
figure it out those type of the common
sense those type it would drive and some
level of respect honesty and stuff like
that yeah I mean you you just can't you
can't lose when you have somewhere like
you have somebody read what's their ass
and you can't if they're they're never
gonna stop there to figure it out one
yeah you can't beat those [ __ ] and
they're gonna if you don't work with
them they're gonna go off and be your
competitor exactly rule number six
reprogram your thinking friend of my
mother's is somebody who was in the
interior design sector and she's about
55 years old she's not doing that well
in interior design right now and unlike
you know all history of our parents
growing up and they really didn't have
to re-educate themselves in their
current business today you have to
reallocate yourself and I said to her I
said why aren't you understanding about
technology and Instagram and she said
well all my friends who are doing bad we
can't believe that anybody will ever
hire an interior decorator open
Instagram I said that's why you have the
problem you have right now you're doing
exactly the same thing you've been doing
since oh wait you think somebody in the
world of government uh something uh
that's going to save you and you're not
changing at all and you're not finding
new friends that are doing things a
different way so it's not about no
longer we were kids when we were 18
years old it's about everybody in the
world has to reprogram the way they
think rule number seven figure things
out you know Barbara Barbara on the show
as a technique and I've seen it
highlighted a couple of different ways
with throughout the book
a lot of people write down what they
hate write down what they love and they
start focusing more on what they love
and start trying to outsource and/or get
done with what they hate and they keep
focusing on what they love and what that
does is that brings them over to that
place in life where they want to be
because they're acknowledging what they
hate and they acknowledging what they
love and if they make an effort to
outsource this or get this out or stop
doing or stop dealing with these people
or stop having these thoughts or being
proactive to get this thing right they
started they start to lean more towards
here in life
Wow that's it's in a way it's sort of
like a visualization right you're using
progress every time you check one of
those things off the list yeah you know
III this is not in the book but I have a
I have a dear friend she's a hair
stylist in Vegas and she wrote down a
list she was like I love doing here cuz
I love the way it makes people feel but
I hate standing in the in this beauty
salon because those women in there just
gossiping and there's nothing of value
there I don't want to stand on my feet
all day and I don't want I don't want to
touch all these dyes that could give me
cancer but I do want to live somewhere
by a beach I want to be my own
entrepreneur and I want to make up my
own hours so she started to look at that
and she started realized the weaknesses
she had is she hated accounting legal
and all these things that she may not
have known she started looking at this
list and doing some and as she started
to do more of what she loved and less of
what she hated she started to say hey if
you're an accountant or an attorney or
female you know I'll come to your house
and I'll do your hair and I'll be your
outcome here every month and do your
hair every two weeks you on the flip
side handle my accounting or legal fees
or whatever the case is so now she got
out of the shop she's making just as
much money doing that because they refer
her to more friends who come on over she
has a better network here so now she's
got another shop and she feels good
about it because she's changing their
lives and make them feel good about
themselves
yeah and on the flip side she's gotten a
couple of Airbnb s and she overs during
the day and she's now living you know
she has a house in California that she
goes out and visits every once in a
while she stays on the beach every
weekend talking back to Las Vegas that's
what she does it's two three years yeah
but it worked because she kept looking
at this direction to go to and trying to
find a way to get these things out of
the way
I also folks at home like you pay
attention like that this is who would
think that there that is a job that does
not exist I'm a mobile hairstylist for
people that provide professional
services and I trade those services so
that I can not have to be like yeah if
you've ever wondered if what you want
out there in life is available to you
it's there is absolutely you'll figure
it out
rule number eight use the 80/20 rule
everything is the one thing you could do
this year to help you drastically
increase your revenue or income with
everything that you're doing is it you
know the FUBU thing or reinvesting back
in yourself is it taking a couple things
and going all in with a few things or I
think today you know if I was going to
maximize and it would have to be you
know really looking at the 80/20 at the
company and personally meaning what is
the 20% of stuff that is creating 80% of
the revenue and or joy or time in my
life whether it's personally or whether
cases and really digging deep into that
thing and a lot of times people don't
want to look at the 80/20 I do look at
it as often as I can but I'm human as
well I get caught up in some things that
may be from a reason I think needs to be
done and I and I get off track but I
have to go back to my goals and look at
them but yeah it would be the 80/20 like
what are what are what are providing the
the 80% of revenue and/or joy from my
staff and myself and keep people there
rule number nine take control of your
life what did you find fascinating about
Tyler the Creator from our future I
found that he was he was a young kid but
he was extremely disciplined and however
he put his self together and he would do
various things you know what you'll
notice on on fifteen of these subjects
is they all do various different things
but it's the same exact thing and you'll
notice that we we no longer are take
control of our large many of us we allow
the rest of the world to take care take
take our responsibilities from us and
make us their problem right so we have
to be selfish and I looked at it in a
certain way that Tyler was being selfish
in the same way I'll give you an example
I'll get right back to how Tyler is when
we wake up in the morning we usually
have a hundred emails and then we then
go and look on social media and we then
kiss the kids or the
the husband the wife whatever and run
out we go on you know we get in the car
and we listen to the news in the entire
world blew up and then we get to the
office with dealing with everybody else
we get home cook for the kids or maybe
the husband wife or the roommate and
then we started all over again well what
I noticed with the people earlier on in
their in their lives or in their day
what they do the first 90 minutes is
they get up they don't answer any emails
for the first hour because they don't
care about everybody else's problems
they send out email but they won't
answer everybody else's because we're so
busy taking care of everybody else's
problems they won't look at social media
because you get social media depression
because everybody on social media is
doing great they got a big car they're
all beautiful they all got big butts or
skinny butts whatever you like right
right you don't even put any time in so
what these people do is they won't
answer any mean email because they look
at their inbox as their defense they
look at the outbox opens they'll send
out all these emails they won't look at
social media they'll go ahead and take
time and schedule time with their kids
that wife whoever it is for the next
night or tomorrow whatever the case is
because they know they keep saying we'll
hang out they'll never get to it they
eat something healthy they'll do four
sets of 25 like you said you'll do four
sets of 25 push-ups get the adrenaline
running then they'll get out there and
they'll start doing things and what
people would usually don't do is they
never take time for themselves to ask
themselves who do they want to be
tomorrow next year in ten years
and Tyler even as a young kid he'll go
out there and he'll sit in a tree for an
hour with his friends yeah they're just
in the tree because we usually forget
who we wanted to be we're answering
everybody else around where a mother or
a father were a husband where or whoever
else and he takes up about an hour a day
and sits the tree and writes everything
down he doesn't put it on his cell phone
he doesn't put it in his smartphone on
the tablet and he used that as a Bible
and every day keeps navigating him
towards success and I've noticed that
every person in the book does the same
exact thing in one form or another they
may do it at midnight they may do it in
the morning time but they all give
praise they think what they have around
them and then they see how they can
build on it by thinking about who they
want to be instead of letting everybody
else in the world tell them what they
want from them and rule number ten the
last one before some very special bonus
let's be a shark you look at someone
like a Mark Cuban the man has more money
than God and that's what you got to use
against them you have to say do you
really think that mark cares about the
little fifty thousand hundred thousand
dollars that he's gonna spend on you he
doesn't love you we see him on the side
of basketball courts all the time
I'm gonna say hey do you want to have to
wait till the season's over to talk to
your partner think about that Barbara
brilliant woman but you know wait do you
really want to deal with a real estate
agent you have a clothing company Kevin
O'Leary
we all can pick up one who pick on him
he's he's that's just like beating a
puppy he's an a-hole he's uh he wants
royalties he's just a miserable person
so that's easy anyway I can go on about
the Sharks but it's all like chess and
trust me they use it against me just as
well and it's fun but think about this
if you ever beat another shark you'd be
so filthy rich people that you not only
embarrass them on national television
with you're also making a profit at the
same time
now I've got three very special Daymond
John bonus clips around using your fears
taking care of your health and believing
in yourself a little bit more but before
that my question the day is have you
read any of Daymond John's books and if
so which ones that you like the most
what's the best first Daymond John book
to start on leave it down the comments
below really curious to find out thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clips
I think we all fear there's a couple
things we won't probably fear being
judged unfairly not being able to
provide for our loved ones and our
family death and losing people that we
love I think those a lot of things but
the fair our cells are often about the
fear of being able to be acknowledged
and or the fear of failing and people
looking at you as a failure because you
you as a human need if you want to get
out of it babies that don't get loved
literally die yeah so like human
connection you want to be accepted and
you have to always second-guess yourself
I second-guess myself every day right
and and it's a fear of saying there's no
point in my life that I didn't have fear
and I call it a healthy paranoia in
business who was doing well okay well
the hot clothing line last five years
Damon did you get bit by the Apple you
know did you bite the Apple one so get
hit by lightning no I got to do it again
all right are you gonna do all right you
failed in the next three launches what
are you gonna do it no I gotta do it
again oh I got to share this idea of Who
I am with the world I want to empower
other entrepreneurs but I'm Dyslexic I'm
gonna write a book are you kidding me
people gonna laugh at me right you know
you're gonna go on to be on a TV show
you what do you - I'm not articulate I
didn't I didn't um I didn't go to
college you know you have people like
Mark Cuban he's a billionaire sitting
next to me you know I'm a couple of
hundred million short I mean you know
how am I gonna debate against him all
right I gotta I gotta have a mental judo
game I got to create a chess board
against him
I can't lose his deal all right all
right mark you I'm gonna give you a
billion dollars but you know just like
when you have a house you only sleep in
one bedroom right mark has a mansion I'm
sleeping in one bedroom and I'm here for
you you're the bedroom mind man mark
around screw him and not bang I get them
and I get them out of the deal you know
fear of well you know am I am i leaving
my daughters inheritance e or a legacy
how would how will they perceive me you
know hear of making my daughter's public
people where now they have pressure on
them and I don't want I want to hide
them from everybody or in fear of
anything else you know the President of
the United States President Obama made
me a president presidential ambassador
for global
rinoa I can never let him down right
yeah it's always gonna be some level of
fear and that fear is good if it's
healthy you know we all talk about
business all the time but the aspect of
health is the most important part nobody
talks about it yeah nobody talks about
it
most business men and women you go
around and you're traveling all the time
you know you know the the best things
then you're you're a two and three
dinners a night you're drinking because
you're born with a lot of people you're
drinkers you're happy because you're all
you know you're not sleeping you're in
between climates and things of that
nature and then all of a sudden it
implodes and you have nothing left
entrepreneurship is natural to everybody
right we wake up as kids and we tell
everybody we're gonna be Superman or
superwoman we're gonna change the world
and everything else like that what
happens is complacency is taught you
[ __ ] you can't do that you won't do that
it can't happen you can embarrass
yourself you're gonna embarrass us so
what happens is really the people around
us who put us in a certain box now they
may be doing it because they care about
you and say listen son or daughter I've
grown up in my life and they may have
grown up in the day and age where one
parent could work and other could stay
at home right or that you had to have an
education and rely on the government or
a company but it is something that is in
all of us every kid is open minded to
changing the world and I grew up a
dyslexic kid who got left back all kind
of issues but my mother made me feel
like I can conquer the entire world so
it's all about the parents and the
people around us who who give us those
dreams and those aspirations on what we
could do but entrepreneurship is very
easy it really is you know it's harder
than being an entrepreneur being a
mother or a parent is being it's harder
than being an entrepreneur raising a
child or a family ten times harder to be
an entrepreneur you can't just give away
your kid you can close the company solve
the problem with the kid right
that is that that is that is ten times
harder so everybody listen to this who
was a parent you are an entrepreneur you
know can do it the most important work
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]